[Music]
[Applause]
all right uh Nate Burleson one of our
good buddies a very busy man NFL today
on CBS Nickelodeon NFL network analyst
CBS Morning host and uh former NFL wide
receiver and I don't know if there's
another guy who's ever played in the NFL
who played in a playoff game with the
Lions
the Seahawks and the Vikings
Nate Burleson joins us now are you the
only man who's ever played in the NFL
who's played in playoff games for those
three teams
I might be I might be I don't know if
that says a lot about me as a talent or
a lot about the fact that I played for
multiple teams around my 11 year career
but either way though you know I'm
thankful that I actually had a chance to
taste the playoffs because we know a lot
of guys that bought out in this league
that never got to the postseason but I'm
glad to be here it's good to see you
again I'm upset that I can't do it in
person but thank you for having me on uh
how are the kids
they're good they're good the kids are
doing good uh I have two older boys who
are in High School playing varsity
basketball together they just finished
varsity football together and if you
check out my Ig oh no I saw it yesterday
I saw I saw Dad going crazy when uh one
of your sons went in for a back door cut
and uh and dunked
yeah so you know I was uh doing what the
kids do with his head top he caught a
body as they like to say
um you know and he he climbed the ladder
and shoved it down listen I get it
there's parents that are there to
casually enjoy the game that ain't me I
am going to show up and show out for my
boy especially when he shocks the gym
like that and they shot one of the best
teams in Jersey so I had a good time
watching is he playing basketball or
football in college
the wild thing is he chose to play wide
receiver he's 6-3 pure shooter and as
you can see he got hops but he thought
to himself 6-3 wide receiver as long as
I improve in college and put some
strength on I'll have a chance to go to
the league here here's the the twist in
his um his decision to go to the
University of Nevada and play wide
receiver one of the coaches there for
the football team said look we know
you're one of the top shooters in Jersey
you can play basketball here if you want
I think at that point he said oh they
must really want me if they said I can
play two sports in college I like that
yeah what conversation did you have with
your uh Sons about what happened in
Cincinnati Monday night
you know it was a tough conversation
I'll take you inside the kitchen
um
I'm sitting there this is maybe an hour
after it all went down and we're talking
about the more Hamlin and his family and
we're just praying and sending goodbyes
crossing our fingers just hoping that we
get good news sooner than later my wife
is sitting there and she just kind of
projects into the air you know this is
why it's tough to watch our kids play
football this is why I don't want them
to play football my 16 year old who was
6'4 200 tight end he loves the sport and
he's he he paused for a second
he said Mom I'm going to play football
and then he followed it by saying you
know this is a rarity it doesn't happen
often and you know I in that moment when
my wife said that there was two sides of
me one side fully agreed with her and
validated her feelings because part of
me felt that way but then there was
another side of me
um and and just being honest and
transparent with me I thought to myself
and this is this is what we signed up
for not necessarily that I'm not talking
about Demar Hamlin being on the ground
Max coming out you know performing CPR
not that part of it but injuries no
matter where on the spectrum they fall
everything from your run-of-the-mill
sprained ankle to concussions broken
bones or ligaments we sign up for all of
that
Nate I say this to my audience usually a
couple of times a year at least once a
year if you stood on the sidelines of an
NFL game
you would never let your son play
football
because the sounds
the speed
football doesn't do it justice
it it doesn't you know when you're
watching it at home even with the
microphones and the 4K cameras
it it it doesn't really put it into
perspective until you're watching it in
person I remember being removed from the
game and and going into retirement and
just doing Studio work for like the
first two or three years
and I finally went to a game it took me
about three years to go to a game sit on
the sideline and work
um as a sideline reporter for the NFL
Network now I remember being there with
some people I work with
and I looked over and I said man these
guys are big fantastic strong and these
hits these heads and one of them looked
at me like with this wild faithful
expression said bro you used to do that
what are you talking about and for a
quick second I forgot that I was one of
those guys who went out there and put
everything on the line because they did
get so much bigger and faster and
stronger since the last time I played
I'll give you another story and I don't
want to hit you with too many stories I
want to answer every question you throw
my way but I remember uh my second year
in the league
I got banged up pretty good this is
Minnesota Vikings name black and blue
division NFC North and the OG's the Vets
um you know they were saying whenever
you play Within this division teams like
Green Bay the Lions especially Chicago
and Chicago they call it black and blue
because your body will be black and blue
I played in one of those division games
and my body was beat up the next day in
the weight room I'm on the bench press
one side of my body is lifting up the
weight the other side is struggling I'm
just like what is going on I changed the
way decreased it same thing I could not
lift with the right side somebody
recommended going to a chiropractor I go
to this chiropractor
they hooked me up got all these tubes
and and these patches and electrodes and
all kind of stuff measuring my muscle
function
on the right side of my body
it was about 15 muscle activity so at
some point I must have pinched some
nerve that shut down most of the right
side of my body all the muscles that I
used to move with so that kind of
explained it you know it was shocking
but it explained it I'm like okay that's
why I'm struggling to lift weights in
the weight room and then the
chiropractor said something I would
never forget he said um
you know you know playing this this game
is rough and I'm like yeah you know I've
been playing it my whole life he's like
yeah yeah but you know going through
what you go through it's like it's like
getting in a car accident I'm like
really he's like yeah it's like getting
in a car accident I'm like wow getting
in the playing an NFL season is like
getting in the car accident he's like no
no no no every time you get hit it's
like getting into a car accident
and I was like
oh
well at that point and we talk about
concussions but really we should be
talking about car wrecks
to let people understand exactly what
you know that feeling is like it's not
just your head trauma if you have one
it's your body trauma but I was also
wondering about this the bigger picture
the serious picture with Demar Hamlin uh
yeah by the way we're talking to a Nate
Burleson of CBS
hopefully he gets out of the hospital
but he's in his second year
who's going to take care of him like
like he's not vested but he have to have
three years in the NFL now so yeah
and and there's been a lot of stuff
that's talked about on social media that
let's you know prayers are great
but what happens to Damar Hamlin if he
comes out hopefully can't play football
then what happens medical costs there I
I know Ryan Shazier that you know the
Steelers honored his contract and made
him sort of a Goodwill Ambassador but I
I think looking you know no guaranteed
contract here uh what do you think like
that's the reality of all to this not
necessarily prayers but hopefully he
comes out and then what is life like for
this man
yeah what if Demar Hamlin wasn't a guy
that set up a GoFundMe for his charity
and wasn't active in the community and
didn't bring in the same type of money
that he brought in I think it's upwards
to six or seven million dollars that
maybe he can lean on financially once he
gets done but what if what if he is a
guy that didn't have that that
outpouring of support financially from
all over the world that's the biggest
question you're spot on DP I just feel
like when when guys are playing this
game and the money isn't guaranteed and
some young guys like this who are still
trying to catch their footing and then
secure a bag the first bag their first
contract what happens if it all ends
like that and that's why we fight for
Lifetime Insurance and it seemed
far-fetched when guys first started
saying it when you really pay attention
to the game it is so necessary so you
need three years three games the three
and three to get invested it for what
five years of insurance after you get
done playing and then after that you're
gonna have to figure it out we play our
whole lives our whole lives playing
football to try to make it to the league
I think we should be rewarded with the
rest of our lives being protected in an
insurance policy that can help us with
all of the aches and pains one of the
first meetings I ever remembered in the
NFL was somebody coming in and basically
hitting us with all stats listen you're
gonna die uh earlier than guys your age
that didn't play football because of the
game most likely you have arthritis
before guys that you went to school with
and when it comes to major surgeries
whether it's a knee replacement a hip
replacement you will be more likely to
get those major procedures
when it comes to you being done with
football compared to guys your age and
with all that said this young you know
cocky full of himself ego driven
Elite mindset top one percent of an
athlete we're all sitting there like
I mean I mean it's good to hear but it
ain't gonna be me it ain't gonna be me
it ain't gonna be me and and that's how
we think until you get on that field and
you realize
oh it might be me did they do the right
thing are they going to do the right
thing in the NFL it feels like momentum
is building to not make the bills in
Bengals resume that game play that game
again that we just wipe it out and we do
winning percentage for the uh the seated
teams in the AFC
yeah that's the right move at this point
who cares about the result of what that
game would have been I mean more
importantly uh
I do I'm more concerned about the the
freedom that these guys are going to
need to play with and by that I mean the
physical Freedom going out there pushing
your body to play the game after seeing
something like that
um but more importantly the mental
Freedom what about the mental health of
these guys you know when all that
happened of course at the Forefront it's
Demar Hamlin and his family let me say
that be very clear so I don't want to
seem insensitive or dismissive but then
I started thinking about the players
watching to your streaming down their
faces sitting on knees and then you look
at the coaches and the staff they're
also thinking about the stance the fans
the adults and the kids and then my mind
just opened up and I'm like what about
everybody at home that is traumatic for
everybody involved so if you know that
it is traumatic visually to see
something as jarring as that these
players they need resources to at least
have the option to go talk to somebody
and then go back out on the field and do
their job because with all of that said
I hate to say it but it's something we
say a lot in this business and media and
it applies to all sports
The Show Must Go On yeah because these
guys get played paid to play football
if I let you come back
and play with one quarterback
one game
current quarterback
that is a tough question
um
sheesh
Patrick Mahomes
it has to be because traditional drop
back
five steps seven step I know if I hit my
Mark he's gonna put that ball exactly
where I need it I'll catch it in stride
it'll hit me in between the numbers I'll
run into the end zone but more
importantly if I come out of that break
and I'm playing up against the top tier
DB somebody that's draped all over me
some young cocky cornerback like soft
Gardener or a vet like Jalen Ramsey who
really did a great job on that route he
breaks the pocket Patrick Mahone is now
rolling left I get a secondary route I'm
getting I'm getting draped all over and
then all of a sudden I see Pat move now
get spin out of that and go to the end
zone there's no way I don't care how
good you are as a cornerback there's no
way you can stop me running two routes
in one play sometimes I have time to run
three I'm going here here and then I'm
breaking deep because of the scramble
rules that Patrick Mahomes plays with so
I would say Patrick Mahomes it gives me
more opportunity to make big plays
but you could say your constant passage
from Tom Brady
but I listening he's gonna
hit me on the spot I'm gonna I'm gonna
catch the ball get the first down I want
big plays though I want them to play are
you younger than Brady
I am younger than ready yeah I think
Brady's mid mid 40s I'm 41.
how crazy I've always wanted to play in
New England though I always listen there
was when I was a free agency I was a
free free agent twice when I was a free
agent my name floated around and the
paper said like who's interested in a
Burleson the fact that the Patriots
showed just interest I never got a call
my agent never said they really were
interested it was in the papers and I
felt like I made it and I was in the
middle of the NFL playing for teams
legitimately getting paid I was like ooh
the Patriots like me they're watching me
they know who I am he could have played
with Tom Brady
I could have I could have well listen if
I come out of retirement I still can't
he's playing until he's 50. you know
what I'm saying we know that do you
think he plays next year
hell yeah where listen
three spots
um
San Francisco
Tampa of course I would love to see
Bruce come down from the booth you had a
year off come on Bruce Tom needs you oh
wow or back to New England those are the
three spots not Vegas
nah I don't see Tom going to Vegas man I
just
you know I just don't see it it would be
great though because you have a premier
receiver and then you have a great
running back at Josh Jacobs
I just I just don't see it I why would
he go back to New England have you seen
that offense
I've seen that offense but if you have
somebody that come in and call that
office the way that time they have no
weapons Nate I mean you'd have to ask
Edelman and grunt to come back
yeah listen bill go get some some geyser
free agency they'll they'll work in the
draft like they always do more
importantly no it might be listen it
might be bigger than football he wants
the heroes welcome every city we're
naming every city we're naming if if he
doesn't play well in in San Francisco
they'll turn them back if he doesn't
play World in Vegas they'll turn their
back if he goes back to New England no
matter what happens they will love him
there okay you got pretty magic are you
telling me if they would go to the Super
Bowl that they would go you know we're
gonna we're gonna bring in Tom here they
already got enough of a mess there with
Garoppolo and treylands yeah no that's
the fact listen if Purdy takes them to
the Super Bowl it's a rap now I don't I
don't even think Trey Lance is in the
field and Garoppolo is gone
Gail King would be a skilled position
player for the Patriots right now
no doubt because she she does her job
what do they say do your job best of her
ability
great to talk to you
good to talk to you
good luck with your sons and uh congrats
on your success
thank you so much man appreciate you
always leading the way thank you that's
Nate Burleson NFL today on CBS the CBS
Morning Show former NFL wide receiver
we'll take a break we have our play of
the day coming up next year on The Dan
Patrick Show